initiate the action phase actually
taking action taking action through the
action act now
so captions globalization my name is an
entire article by one were to believe
but I believe this entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problem
so a houseful your journey today we're
going to learn how to take action and
also guys if you're watching to hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down in the post below
the quote surrounded my Twitter fries
but also he write down my collective
distinct joy you speak to businesses and
companies and leadership teams and
employees in 2000 without mentioning
names I don't to put you on the spot but
have you gone and talked to a company
that's been in trouble and then spoke
into their team and then check in on
them after you've spoken to their
leadership team and what did that look
like did you notice a noticeable change
did they come to you and tell you that
this has helped our organization out and
our culture is much improved because of
it you mean does my work
I mean sure here's the problem with my
stuff you got to do it and I am NOT I'm
not anybody's like you know mom or dad
I'm not going to do it for you
and I have a very less pair approach of
it I once had a one side ex pliant this
is a bunch of years ago that said what
guarantee do I have that your stuff will
work which my answer was none like I I'm
giving you a tool you can like a hammer
you can use it broadly or narrowly you
can build a table you can build a house
it's the same tool you can use it for
marketing of music completely revitalize
your entire culture and even though I'm
going to sell you the most beautiful
hammer I'm not going to guarantee the
structural integrity of the house right
it's your business you want to ignore
all my stuff ignore it I don't care it's
your any of your business collapses you
know what happens to me nothing like I
don't mean to be cold about it like of
course I want the people I work with to
do well but it's not mine it's theirs
and I take no emotional responsibility
but the decisions they make so yes there
are many people that I've had the
pleasure of working with some who work
for dysfunctional organizations that
went up the hard journey of completely
changing the way they lead and
completely revitalizing their culture
and it has great success
it's not because of me it's because of
them right at the same time there are
many people who came in what an amazing
speech and did nothing you know thanks
that was great you know and I don't it's
of course it's going to fail you know so
I I think that we we have too much
especially in the consulting world or
the design world
everybody's so paternalistic about it my
designers are famous for this right they
get so personally offended when the
client chooses the wrong thing bonus
videos don't they know we're trying to
help them
or who cares like it's their freakin
business right that's what you find
I've had that instead of arguing with
somebody for them to the right choice
which because we genuinely want to help
them what I have found is if you push
the accountability to us because when we
argue we're taking accountability this
is better this will help you we're
taking responsibility accountability but
if we say look we've been doing this a
bunch of years we know more about design
than you do I'm telling you for every
reason that I can outline for you why
this will help you more but if you don't
want to do it that's fine it's your
business do what you want the minute you
switch the accountability and put it all
on them amazingly they're much more open
to your opinion because now they're
responsible one night Chris had gone to
bed I had been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems I we started leaning on the
house still facing bankruptcy still
fighting like crazy I was still
unemployed
he still they still haven't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and I was about to turn off the TV and
there on the the TV there was this
rocket launching and I thought oh my
gosh in it I am going to launch myself
out of bed like a rocket ship like NASA
right here and launch me out of that bed
and I'm going to move so fast that I
don't think I'm going to beat my brain
now here's a really interesting point I
talked a lot about your instincts and
inner wisdom and we can get into this a
little bit later but a lot of us talk
about the fact that you have a gut
feeling but what all this research that
I've done for the book and all the
speaking that I do what I've discovered
that's fascinating is actually when you
set goals when you have an intention on
something that you want to change about
your life your brain helps you what it
does is it opens up a checklist and then
your brain goes to work trying to remind
you yeah of that intention that you set
and it's really important to develop the
skill and I say that word purposefully
the skill of knowing how to hear
that inner wisdom and that intention
kicking in and leaning into it quickly
so for me my brain saying that's it
right there
move as fast as a rocket Mel I wanted to
change my life and I think most people
that are miserable or that are they're
really like dying to be great and dying
to have more we want to change we want
to live a better life we want to create
more for our families we want to be
happier the desire is there again it's
about how do you go from knowledge to
action so the first thing in the story
that's important is realizing that the
answer was in me and my mind was telling
me pay attention could have also been a
bourbon and happens that night anyway
the next morning the alarm goes off
and I pretended NASA was there it's a
stupidest story I literally went five
four three two one I counted out loud
and then I stood up and I'll never
forget standing there in my bedroom it
was dark it was cold it was winter in
Boston and for the first time in three
months I had beaten my habit of hitting
the snooze button I couldn't believe it
and I thought wait a minute counting
backwards that is the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life well the
next morning I used it again and it
worked the next morning I used it again
and it worked the next morning I used it
again and it worked and then I started
to notice something really interesting
there were moments all day long all day
long just like that five-second moment
in bed where I knew knowledge what I
should do and if I didn't move within
five seconds my brain would step in and
talk me out of it every human being has
a five-second window might even be
shorter for you you have about a
five-second window in which you can move
from idea to action before your brain
kicks into full gear and sabotages any
change in behavior because remember your
brain is wired to stop you from doing
things that are
uncomfortable or uncertain or scary it's
your job to learn how to move from those
ideas that could change everything
into acting on people want to know how
to stop the laziness and they will know
how to stop the procrastination and you
know they have some idea in their head
you know some kind of a vision what they
want to do but they don't know where to
start in order start it you know they
don't know where to start
and say they say hey where do I start
and and when's the best time to start
and I have a very simple answer for that
here and now that's it you want to
improve you want to get better you want
to get on a workout program or a clean
diet you want to start a business you
want to write a book or make a movie or
build a house or a computer or put
together some mobile application where
do you start you start right here and
when you start you start right now you
initiate the action aggressively you go
because the idea isn't going to execute
itself and the book isn't going to write
itself and the weights out in the gym
they're not going to move themselves you
have to do it and you have to do it now
and that means you got to stop thinking
about it and stop dreaming about it and
stop researching every aspect of it and
reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it just start doing it
take that
first step and make it happen get after
it get after it here and now take action
whatever you want to do whatever you're
thinking about it you will not get it
until you take action make that move
make it a small step if you want a house
go get a word you know if you want a new
car go get some car freshener take
action make this thing happen for you
and it will happen action action action
you know one thing that uh you know I
can really attribute to every failure in
my life of whether the personal
financial in any kind of way business
whatever it's because of a lack of my
attempt to take action I did not take
action and it kind of changed once I got
the fact that actually is the key um it
changed my life in many many ways
I think stress you can be one of the
things that's very important to note
about stress if the stress primarily
comes from not taking action over
something that you can have some control
over so if I find that some particular
thing is causing me to have stress
that's a warning flag for me what it
means is there's something that I
haven't completely identified perhaps in
my conscious mind that is bothering me
and I haven't yet taken any action I
find as soon as I identify it and make
the first phone call or send off the
first email message or whatever it is
that we're going to do to start to
address that situation even if it's not
solved the mere fact that we're
addressing it dramatically reduces any
stress that might come from it so stress
comes from ignoring things that you
shouldn't be ignoring I think in large
part so stress doesn't come people get
stress
wrong all the time my opinion stress
doesn't come from hard work for example
you know you can be working incredibly
hard and loving it and likewise you can
be out of work and incredibly stressed
over that so and likewise if you kind of
use the you know use that as an analogy
for what I was just talking about if
you're out of work but you're going
through you know a disciplined approach
of you know a series of job interviews
and so on and working to remedy that
situation you're going to be a lot less
stressed than if you're just worrying
about it and doing nothing one of the
functions of belief is taking action we
did a survey of about 2,000 top
entrepreneurs we noticed that one of the
things that people who win in that world
have is a bias for action if they have
an inspiration they act on it I mean how
many of you have ever had a great idea
talked about it thought about it didn't
do it then someone else did it was
successful and you went on I should have
done that maybe it was by that piece of
property was all that we all have that
piece of property we wish we'd bought
you know anyway so we're going to be
looking at the idea that taking action
is part of Law of Attraction so a lot of
people think you just sit in your room
meditate visualize having the perfect
car the perfect house the perfect
relationship then it'll kind of just
come to you and I always say unless you
live at the bottom of the hill where
there's a road probably not going to be
a Cadillac show up in your living room
right so think about this the last six
letters of the word attractions fell
what a cpio in action now there's two
kinds of actions that are critical
there's obvious action if you want a
certain kind of car you should go down
and test-drive it you should find out
how much it cause you should see what it
costs to maintain it you should go you
know spend I like to test drive a car
three or four times go down to the
dealer take a camera stick my head out
the window say take a picture of me I'll
be back to buy it
put it up on my refrigerator look at it
every day eventually you know those kind
of things produce car right saving for
it and so forth but there are also
things called inspired actions all of a
sudden you get an inspiration to do
something and you didn't know what it
was you don't have a sense of like how's
this rationally going to make sense for
me to move forward in my life I'll give
you an example a friend of mine dr.
Ignatius Piazza graduates chiropractic
school he wants to move to Monterey
near Pebble Beach where the golf course
is and he gets there and he says to the
local Chiropractic Association like to
join you or like you to help me get my
practice started they said we don't need
any more chiropractors we have one
chiropractor for every eight people in
this area too many now he could have
said okay let the external reality
control his internal experience but he
doesn't do that he said I'm going to
think about this and visualize it and
believe in it and something will come
that I will do and what came to him to
do was to take six months before he
opened his office and put a pin where he
wanted his office and then concentric
circles knock on every door in every
neighborhood saying hi I'm a new doctor
in town could I ask you a few questions
you know I'm starting this practice
should I open from 5:00 to 9:00 in the
morning and or should I be open from
5:00 until 9:00 at night for people who
have 9 to 5 jobs which would be better
should I advertise in this paper or that
paper should I call it Ignatius Piazza
chiropractic or chiropractic West then
his last question was the 5 an open
house would you like to receive an
invitation they said yes he wrote it
down now over six months he knocked on
12,500 doors talk to 6500 people and
gathered over 4,000 names of people who
said yes I'd like an invitation to your
open house now when he opened his office
six months later in a town that did not
need another chiropractor according to
the professionals his first month in
practice he netted seventy two thousand
dollars in his first year in practice
his gross income was over a million
dollars I was giving a talk to mention
this story just about five years ago and
this happened about 25 years ago someone
said he knocked on my door
and he left his card and two years later
I needed the chiropractor and I called
him because we work with people we know
we've had an experience with right so he
trusted his intuition he took action on
it other people would say oh yes I can't
have what I want you got to be willing
to take the action you can't just wait
for inspiration to act that's the
biggest mistake people make don't wait
to be inspired to do the action you have
to do the action first and then you'll
be inspired so what I would do is I
would sit there and draw up the comic
and I would come up with it but some
days I'd come home from school sit down
go I'm just going to wait for the
inspiration to him you little wait for
the idea to come fully formed when I got
a joke then I'll go draw it and I would
sit there for maybe three or four hours
you go alright screwed I got to get up
and I got to do the process I got to sit
there and just start drawing I don't
even know why or how I'm going to get
there and then two things would come
together and it'll be oh there's an idea
this is the first panel to think about
and then it would come together always
it would not take very long I would
fight that process so much because what
was I doing I was waiting for
inspiration before I acted it's always
the other way around act first then the
inspiration will come draw first then
the inspiration will come just start
shooting then the additional cut just
start moving then the inspiration will
come don't wait so many people wait or
are or tell you they're going to write
this novel or they're going to do this
they're going to make this film they
never do it because they're waiting for
all this stuff to come to them it comes
through doing it don't wait go do it act
now I'm really accepting we need you we
need you we need you you are the 1%
you're the percent that says I'm going
to wake up you are the light workers you
are the ones that have accepted this
call in this lifetime at this time you
have decided to wake up and chosen to
say yes I'm here to be a greater service
and just to feed myself right I'm here
to feed the world I'm here to give love
I'm here to be an expression of that
truth don't hold that back don't play
small we can't we need you and so really
if you are anyone in this room who has
been sitting on that book idea waiting a
little bit longer before you start that
teacher training
or doing ten more teacher trainings
before you actually teach if that's you
guys start and the pressure will be off
I can't begin to tell you I could cry to
saying this the mo the day I taught ego
Eradicator I was two weeks into my
teacher training and I said f it let's
go and I just went and I felt so much
pressure off I felt so much lift because
I just knew I felt this technology must
be shared I can't hold it I can't keep
it for myself I can't just sit in my
apartment by myself like this I got to
give this and sharing it the pressure
this just lifted it was like oh thank
you thank you thank you and I wasn't the
perfect teacher and I look back and I
was teaching Eagle Radek eight or wrong
everyone's arms were like this everyone
was breathing backwards it was a mess
but I did it and I started and in those
moments when we just get to go just go
the pressure is off and then we clear
the path and we are guided to the next
right action and that is the most
magnificent thing that could you right
now I find it quite inspiring you were
in some publicity originally and then at
a certain point you decided that you
wanted to direct can you tell us how you
got from there to here well I was one of
those ladies standing on the side you
know and they work hard and no one no
one ever really gives them a shout-out I
thank you all the publicist in the
corner you know and as a person he loved
film and wanted to make film you're
standing there supporting filmmakers
telling their stories and it's something
I love doing but for me there was always
a little bit of I don't not jealousy but
just like wow that that's great what
they're doing and so at the moment when
I actually started to write and try to
direct my own stuff I was still doing
publicity for other people's films I was
trying to make my own films I was asking
for permission pitching people trying to
get contacts and Network and do all the
things that don't matter
because the only thing that matters is
your work and so when I finally realized
that and started to make small things
and try to move them around festivals
and just you know just share my work you
know the energy behind that positive
intention started
ball rolling and I've only been making
films for five years and I only quit my
job full-time three years ago because I
was still holding on a publicity as a
security blanket and so and so yeah you
know I look at you know each year that's
passed and all I've tried to do is
continue to make work whether I have the
money to make a film a narrative a dock
a commercial a TV show
director the episode of scandal a
documentary about Venus Williams
whatever I cast or II I want to tell
through whatever medium short medium TV
medium commercial medium full-length
documentary feature that's something
that I really learned from Spike Lee not
Jones I'm sure John tonight I'll talk
her lady she was like spec Jennifer but
no ladies exactly um but you know
remember he did commercials with Jordan
he's done it almost as many dots as he's
done narratives he's made a film every
year for the past 20 years when he's
really the blueprint of it's not even a
black filmmaker a filmmaker who's just
continued to make work and so that's
that's not where you're now your book is
titled nothing to lose everything to
gain what does that title mean to you
you know it's a mindset so the mindset
that I had when I was on the street and
when I lived you know in boys homes and
I was in juvenile hall and if the
essence is is when you have nothing to
lose you they're back into a corner or
and you cower and you submit where you
fight your way out and so I've been
backed into a corner a few times both
when I was a kid but then also in my
professional career when I decided to
become an entrepreneur when the
recession hit you know I had to apply
that same mindset now it's your mantra
why do you think so many people don't
live with that mindset today I mean
there's a lot of fear out there fear the
unknown yeah you know what fear is it's
a trap and people are domesticated so to
speak so you know they're comfortable
and if they just realize that they have
nothing to lose you know these
middle-class folks are you know they
think that some of the lives that think
that their reputation with their
neighbors or their credit or their Louie
Vuitton luggage or whatever
is is worth holding on to if they just
ventured out there started a business
took action they realize there's a
better life
thank you guys know what you are a vocal
choice unless no why don't you take from
this video that you're going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
is your business because house without
really ii see what you have to say so
thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love
[Music]